Good morning, John.
Uh, he internet, is pretty great.
It's weird and economically and culturally
diverse.
It's my hobby and it's my job and it's my
passion - and it's my friend.
A lot of the marvelous, weirdness and diversity
of the internet was and is because of a concept
called Net Neutrality.
Basically the idea that all the information
flowing through the pipes of the internet
has to be treated the same way, which is kind
of a new thing.
Other information distribution systems never
really had that rule which allowed for people
who had money to come in and control everything.
But, with the internet, whether you're watching,
like, the most popular television show on
T.V.
right now, or you're just watching me in my
office, talking to the camera and being a
weirdo, or you're looking up net neutrality
articles on Wikipedia, all of that information
has to be treated the same.
The thing is, a lot of companies with a lot
of money, don't want it to be this way.
They would rather say, "Well, if somebody
wants to pay us to deliver their content faster,
and slow everybody else down, then sure, yeah,
we want to do that."
And some companies want to be able to pay
to speed up their content while competitors
can't afford to do that, so that they can
maintain their strangle hold on the psyche
of the American people.
The people who want the internet to remain
neutral are mostly, people.
We often feel like people, just normal people,
don't actually have that much influence on
how the American government is going to get
run.
Now, with Net Neutrality, this is compounded
by the fact that both technologically and
legally complected.
So, it's kinda hard to get people on board
with the regulations, especially when pro-business
people can just say, "Big government wants
to regulate the awesomest thing ever!"
And that sounds a little scary; we don't want
the government to regulate the internet.
I don't like the idea of that!
But, we're not really talking about them regulating
the internet, we're talking about them regulating
the companies that deliver the internet.
So it's really come down to a vocal and active
group of people on the internet -- it's not
a very big group of people -- being the only
folks who are championing net neutrality.
And, honestly, I didn't have a lot of hope
that we'd actually win.
Like, not a big win.
Maybe we'd force a middle course, you know?
But, look, Tom Wheeler of the FCC used to
work for the cable industry, and they hate
net neutrality.
And most individual people don't care about
net neutrality; they don't even know what
net neutrality is.
And practically all of the money being spent
by lobbyists is being spent to lobby for the
destruction of net neutrality.
And yet, here I say it, in the United States
of America, where the internet has been reclassified
as a public utility, giving the government,
finally, the power to keep the internet neutral.
And the new FCC rules guarantee,that they
will do that.
We...won.
We won!
It's almost a foreign idea to me.
But we won.
And it's a win against the lobbyists and against
corporate interests in a situation where there
was no reason for the government to do the
right thing, except that it was the right
thing.
The other thing is that this really came down
to party lines, like there were three democrats
voting on the FCC and two republicans.
And the republicans voted against net neutrality.
So whenever people say, "It doesn't matter,
both sides are the same side," then something
huge like this happens that would've totally
gone the other wa, if there had been a different
administration in the White House.
And it's huge!
This is hugely important for the future of
the internet.
It's hugely important for the future of me.
But it was dragged out over a long time, and
it was complicated and it wasn't really sure
when it was gonna actually happen and be done
with.
So it's just not very exciting, but that's
how these things happen.
And I would feel like a bit of a grapefruit
if I didn't say thank you to all of the people
who fought and worked hard to make the government
realize that they needed to keep the internet
neutral.
And also, to all of the people in the actual
government who decided to do this despite
the fact that they're gonna make a lot of
corporations angry, and we know that those
corporations have a lot of power in America.
And also, I would feel bad if i didn't just
take a little moment to celebrate and be happy
about this thing that has finally happened
after a really long time of working on it.
So, THANK YOU EVERYONE, THIS IS AWESOME!
HUZZAH!!
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
Oh look, Jimmy Carter's found his bed.
Find a job!
John: Suddenly, you're just an old man playing
a video game with extremely out of date graphics.
Hank: I'm just gonna get the coins and star.
Katherine: You are such a nugget!
Hank: This is the first time Bill Clinton
has EVER FLIRTED!
Are you guys fighting over me right now?
Thank you Mario!
But the princess is in another castle.
John: Why does Toad talk like that?
Hank: That's what he sounds like.